there the white house finally admitting
they are afraid to let president biden
talk to the media
he takes questions nearly every day he's
out from the press
that is not something we recommend in
fact a lot of times we say don't take
questions you know but he's going to do
what he wants to
because he's the president of the united
states and while the president does take
some questions from time to time he
mostly listens to that advice
president can you pass voting rights
with the senate full of the filibuster
in its current form do you think
i can talk
thank you very much mr president i think
it's time for our friends of the press
to leave there
i'm sorry i'm gonna just last question
i'll take and i said i'm really gonna be
in trouble
he's gonna get in trouble um shannon i
wanna go to you you're a brilliant
reporter always ask the tough questions
and so my question is the media allowed
this to happen during the campaign
trail he stayed in the basement i
reported there many times and it was
hard to really get
questions in to the president so are
they to blame for this problem
listen i got to think that every white
house press secretary at some point
secretly says this to themselves like
gosh i wish they would not answer
questions because then i got to go out
there and clean up whatever they say
and then this white house likes to be
pretty controlled with him he's on
teleprompter a lot when he is out there
speaking
he's got notes um they're very careful
and as you said during the campaign that
was sort of the tone that they set
but once somebody's in the white house
these reporters want to get at them they
want questions answered they want to be
able to talk to him directly and frankly
they got spoiled during the last
administration because president trump
could not walk to marine one without
stopping
talking i mean sometimes 20 30 minutes
uh to these reporters he took questions
everyone he liked sparring with them
so i think some of these uh press corps
folks they may not admit it but i think
at least where that's concerned they
miss the former president that ability
to engage with
him yeah love her hate him he gave a lot
of access so one
let me go to you um you know this guy
was once known the president of the
united states as
the greatest retail politician they
loved him being out there talking with
people
so what happened
well i think he still is a great retail
politician but you know i i just want to
reiterate something shannon said i've
been a white house correspondent
and in all my associations with press
secretaries not only at the white house
but up on capitol hill
city hall state houses corporations
all press secretaries want to be
gatekeepers their job is to make their
principal look
good so lawrence what they want to do is
they want to control
the type of questions and this
environment they don't want
gotcha questions right they don't want
stumble they don't want him
unprepared uh that's what everybody
wants for
you know the person they're representing
as a press secretary
and i think that it has some added
moment right now because a lot of people
on the right
they per you know perpetuate perpetuate
this idea oh biden's an old guy he
doesn't know what he's doing
he stutters all this kind of stuff so i
think for her to say
look i think you and i have issues i i
wouldn't go that far
i mean i just think that all of us uh
have our moments and press secretaries
i mean they're like makeup artists they
want you to look good
yeah they want them to look good jesse
but the problem is
that when you compare him to former
presidents it's not
quite operating the same
no but i don't even need to hear from
biden at this point i don't trust the
guy he said he was a moderate
and he got in there and he broke the
bank and the border
i don't even think democrats need to
hear from joe biden nancy and chuck are
running congress
his brain trust is running the white
house ron klain the big lobbyists and a
bunch of other guys
they make all the decisions and susan
rice is basically
in there to have obama have his eyes and
ears on the whole operation
i mean they want the guy scripted he
goes off script he calls texans
neanderthals
he was asked about iran in china the
other day he looked like he was gonna
have a panic attack like he was gonna
say something
consequential i think this country is
leaderless right now we're a
superpower we can coast we're all muscle
but not forever
this guy is just attacks and spend
liberal he's not even
trying to persuade people anymore he's
not inspiring anybody and probably the
less he says the better because you more
you know about what he's doing the less
you'll like it we elected the anti-trump
a boring listless guy that stays inside
and doesn't really
charge people up and then in four years
you know we'll probably get
bored and broke and we'll elect the
opposite a young
charismatic creative guy like you
lawrence oh that was good
thanks man uh judge so i got to go to
you
it was really good uh judge i got to go
to you because
you know the last campaign was about
tone it was about personality difference
not really about policy
you know you're a supporter of the
former president do you think there's
going to be some buyer's remorse i mean
it doesn't feel good when your taxes are
going it doesn't feel good when the
the borrower is open so what what what's
going to happen
well there's already buyer's remorse are
you kidding i mean
everybody is like first of all he wants
to he wants to
he's going to raise taxes i mean he's
he's allowing you know the
southern border to be completely open
but i want to comment about one thing
and that is that we just heard president
biden
talk about the fact that he was going to
get in trouble when he walked back to
the podium
he says i'll answer this question but
i'm going to get in trouble do you
remember
last week when he couldn't find his mask
he was up there dithering around uh the
podium like looking for his mask he said
i'm gonna get in trouble
who's he getting in trouble with this is
like proof positive to me that somebody
else is calling the shots
because he's afraid of someone he always
says he's gonna get in trouble who are
you getting in trouble with
aren't you your own man i mean come on
and america knows it
and i i think they they everybody gets
it yeah he gets in trouble because when
he's asked about the border he ends up
calling the crisis and then his
press secretary has to walk it back
because he
has to go clean it up yep hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else